we now introduce a new type of random
variable the exponential random variable
it has a probability density function
that is determined by a single parameter
lambda which is a positive number and
the form of the PDF is as shown here
note that the PDF is equal to zero when
X is negative which means that negative
values of X will not occur they have
zero probability and so a random
variable is a non-negative random
variable the shape of the PDF is as
shown in this diagram its 0 for negative
values and then for positive values it
starts off it starts off at the value
equal to lambda this is because if you
plug in X equal to 0 in this expression
you get lambda times e to the 0 which
leaves you just with the lambda so it
starts off at lambda and then it decays
at the rate of lambda notice that when
lambda is small the initial value of the
PDF is small but then the decay rate is
also small so that the PDF extends over
a large range of X's on the other hand
when lambda is large then the PDF starts
large so there's a fair amount of
probability in the vicinity of 0 but
then it decades pretty fast so there's
much less probability for larger values
of X another observation to make is that
the shape of this exponential PDF is
quite similar to the shape of the
geometric PDF that we have seen before
the only difference being that here we
have a discrete distribution but here we
have a continuous analogue of that
distribution let us now carry out a
calculation let us fix some positive
number a and let us calculate the
probability that our random variable
takes a value larger than or equal to a
so what we're trying to do is to
calculate the probability that the
random variable falls inside this
interval from a to infinity whenever we
have a PDF we can calculate the
probability of falling inside an
interval by integrating over that
interval
value of the PDF therefore we have to
calculate this particular integral and
at this point we can recall a fact from
calculus namely that the integral of the
function e to the ax is 1 over a times e
to the ax we can use this fact by making
the correspondence between a and minus
lambda and using this correspondence we
can now continue the calculation of our
integral we have a factor of lambda and
then a factor of 1 over a where a stands
for minus lambda so we get a minus 1
over lambda and then the same
exponential function e to the minus
lambda X and because the range of the
integration is from a to infinity we
need to evaluate the integral at a and
infinity and take the difference now
this lambda cancels that lambda were
left with a minus sign and from the
upper limit we get e to the minus lambda
times infinity and then from the second
term we have a minus sign that cancels
with that minus sign and gives us a plus
term plus e to the minus lambda a now e
to the minus infinity is 0 and so we're
left just with the last term and the
answer is e to the minus lambda a so
this gives us the tail probability for
an exponential random variable it tells
us that the probability of falling
higher than a certain number falls off
exponentially with that certain number
an interesting additional observation if
we let a equal to 0 in this calculation
we obtain the integral of the PDF over
the entire range of X's and in that case
this probability becomes
to the minus lambda 0 which is equal to
1 so we have indeed verified that the
integral of this PDF is equal to 1 as it
should be now let us move to the
calculation of the expected value of
this random variable we can use the
definition since the PDF is nonzero only
for positive values of X we only need to
integrate from 0 to infinity we
integrate x times the PDF and this is an
integral that you may have encountered
at some point before it is evaluated by
using integration by parts and the final
answer turns out to be 1 over lambda
regarding the calculation of the
expected value of the square of the
random variable we need to write down a
similar integral except that now we will
have here x squared this is just another
integration by parts only a little more
tedious and the answer turns out to be 2
over lambda squared finally to calculate
the variance we use the handy formula
that we have
and the expected value of x squared is
this term the expected value of X is
this term when we square it it becomes
similar to this term but we have here a
2 there we have a 1 and so we're left
with just 1 over lambda squared and this
is the variance of the exponential
random variable
notice that when lambda is small the PDF
as we discussed before falls off very
slowly which means that large X's are
also quite possible and so the average
of this random variable will be on the
higher side the PDF extends over a large
range and that translates into having a
large mean and because the when that
happens the PDF actually spreads the
variance also increases and this is
reflected in this formula for the
variance the exponential random variable
is in many ways similar to the geometric
for example the expression for the mean
which is 1 over lambda can be contrasted
with the expression for the mean of the
geometric which is 1 over P and the
relationship between these two
distributions the discrete and the
continuous analog is a theme that we
will revisit several times at this point
let me just say that the exponential
random variable is used to model many
important and real-world phenomena
generally it models the time that we
have to wait until something happens in
the discrete case the geometric random
variable models the time until we see a
success for the first time in the
continuous case an exponential can be
used to model the time until a customer
arrives the time until a light bulb
burns out the time until a machine
breaks down the time until you receive
an email or maybe the time until a
meteorite falls on your house